in combat shielding your team is more
important than dealing damage the shield
projectors battery will not recharge if
it's being used pull the trigger only
when a teammate is about to take damage
so the battery starts recharging sooner
the shield projector has considerable
range try to get up high and protect
your teammates from afar the orbital
barrage can be used defensively to force
the monster away from an object for a
downed hunter the laser cutter is
extremely accurate go for headshots or
holes in the monster's armor use your
cloak to protect your team in capped
hunters and high-value targets like your
medic can benefit from a well-timed
cloak use your UAV to scout ahead for
the monster but don't stray too far your
body is vulnerable once you track the
monster return to your body and regroup
with the team
your sentry guns can be used to create a
defensible area deploy your sentry guns
as soon as you enter combat but make
sure you spread them out a good monster
will destroy clustered sentry guns with
a single attack once you have deployed
all of your sentry guns switch to your
guided missile launcher and join the
battle sentry guns can be deployed near
incap teammates to force the monster
away from an easy kill before the mobile
arena expires launch your UAV and track
the monster guided missiles will
detonate when they get close to the
monster pinpoint accuracy is not
required you can fire multiple missiles
and guide them all to the same point
with your laser use your cloak to
protect your team in capped hunters and
high-value targets like your medic can
benefit from a well-timed cloak
coordinate with assault to get the most
benefit out of the damage amplifier when
assault can't engage switch to your rail
cannon and deliver the damage personally
the rail cannon can deliver reduce
damage when shooting through walls use
this in combination with dust tagging to
attack the target without being seen if
the monster is suspected to be nearby
dust tag and find out if timed properly
dust tagging can be dropped in front of
a monsters path
you